i would say i would definitely make a
distinction and say that humans have
always done cosmology meaning that we've
always wanted to understand our origins
you know even going right back to
creation stories or creation myths you
know I would say that I would go as far
as saying the Adam and Eve story how to
start in the beginning you know the
earth was without form and we were in
this void I forget the exact statement
of that but so we've always been doing
cosmology I would say that cosmology is
now a branch is basically a branch of
physics of the physical sciences that
correlates or looks at phenomenon that
physics or the everyday physics that
that we study and in a sense applies
that to the whole did to the universe as
a whole and in you know and as we do
that we learn that we can actually
account for a lot of things such as how
stars and galaxies and planets are sort
of formed on larger scales but we also
learn new physics we also can use cause
this by looking at to the universe as a
whole and the largest distances we can
imagine we can learn something about the
smallest things here like you know like
atomic physics particle physics physics
of the sub in the sub-nuclear domain so
it really is the cosmology is the
physics that connects the smallest
things in the universe to the larger
studies in the universe
the quantum gravity you can break this
up into actually the title of this
particular theoretical framework the
word loop and when you think of loop you
literally think of a hula hoop think of
that shape so you have a hulu and i can
imagine link in a bunch bunch of those
hula hoops together and making you know
some sort of fabric of hula hoops when I
look from far away that's a loop part
quantum of course is quantum as in
Qantas creat quantum mechanics that you
know one of the things we learn from
quantum mechanics is that how the
electron actually occupies the itself in
the hydrogen atom is through quantized
positions and energy levels discrete
jumps in positions and energy levels
that sort of you know of course a very
vast either way of talking about choir
mechanics but that's one way we can
think about it so that's a quantum point
and the most important part about loop
quantum gravity is a gravity part so
really what loop quantum gravity is is a
theory of quantum gravity of unifying
quantum mechanics that's been so
successful and most of our technology
for example uses quantum mechanics with
the other successful paradigm of physics
which is Einsteins theory of general
relativity I'm having to do with matter
and energy being able to walk the very
fabric of space and time and loop
quantum gravity another if you now
another way of combining the quantum
with the gravity part now that I gave
you the Einstein in view that the fabric
of space-time could be warped now
imagine you say okay therefore i have an
atom of space and time so let's forget
the time partner but i have an atom a
piece of space that appears to be
continuous on large scales distance
scales but when I actually go to very
very small scales how small put 30 40 s
arm in front of a centimeter ok decimal
points and we're talking about that
distance scale
okay so called the plank distance scale
we actually start seeing that space the
fabric of space comes in atomistic
chunks just like the atom like the
hydrogen atom was a quantum became a
quantum entity so we move from this
continuous description of space and time
to act mystic description of space and
time and that's and the loops of
themselves the V if you want to think of
them at all the objects okay that you
know when they link up together those
are the atomistic objects in a sense of
of the fabric of space-time and when
they link up together there is some sort
of weave of fabric that I see just like
you look at my shirt seems to be smooth
but when I go in right I actually see
the fabric of the threads that that link
up together in that case it will be the
hula hoops of the fabric of space and
time the one weird concept of Luke
Parker that's what i think is pretty
cool is that the loops themselves
defined space so in other words if i
give you a loop and loop on a gravity
space only exists in the loop but
outside the loop there's no space so
Luke wanna grab gravity also
incorporates the idea of there being no
space empty space is still something
loop quantum gravity but there is
actually a notion of no sleep
how does it wanna grab the computer
string theory is very much actually an
active role I'm an active line of
research for some people right now in
that they are trying to connect or think
of ways in which string theory and look
crime quantum gravity could actually be
unified not unified but related to each
other because right as it stands right
now there are different pictures so to
speak of quantum gravity of how you
marry quantum physics with gravity how
you link space-time the arena that
matter works moves in with actually Matt
on quantum mechanics which does so well
describe it matter so they differ in a
sense one way to contrast him is that
string theory is based on a form of
matter in a sense that we will about you
know that is string light rather than
point like like optimistic so you take
matter I don't want to cut my finger up
but use that as an example but yeah i
can divide my de molecules my finger
down to the Planck length string theory
says when i get to that length scale
that optimistic point actually resolves
itself to be a string like vibration of
energy and depend on the different
vibrational frequencies or how the
string rotates may be all right or how
it wraps onto itself I get the
appearance of different types of matter
but it's a theory really of
fundamentally of matter moving in
space-time so in a sense we call that a
background dependent formulation of
quantum gravity versus loop quantum
gravity which doesn't require a
background space-time itself defines the
background string theory is a theory
that starts out positive a form a string
like form of matter but as string light
form of matter propagates or moves in a
background space-time now in loop
quantum gravity there is no background
space-time it's the loops
that define the background space time
because there can outside of these loops
okay there is no space time so Lou
quantum gravity is said to be a
relational theory it if I depend on how
I link these loops quantum loops of
space time together will give me space
time relationships okay so in that
that's more the so-called light lit like
Mitzi and viewpoint of space-time that
is relational this sense is nothing more
than you know is the not just about some
space in between you but a sense of
foreigners in nearness that's a
relationship and so loop quantum gravity
takes to that view point where it
doesn't require a background in
space-time which is one of the
fundamental postulates of Einstein's
theory of general relativity that laws
of physics should be in should not care
about the positions or the background
space-time that an observer say like you
and I of a planet arm is situated there
should be invariant under one state of
motion or position where string theory
starts out with them as an assumption
and then they can actually get gravity
back from that assumption so that's the
way one way in which there